It says no kale or very little. This person is talking about their genetic review information.
And the reason why you don't want a lot of kale with cancer patients has to do with your, well probably has to do with your AWS genes, but it also has to do with
kale has the highest amount of nitric oxide is, you know, any vegetable, I mean, by far, spinach is number two, but kale has probably three to four times the nitric oxide.
Nitric oxide is great if you don't have cancer. If you have cancer, nitric oxide increases, what's called endothelial growth factor endothelial growth factor.
Increases your ability to grow new vessels, what's called that Jeff vascular endothelial growth factor increases the ability to grow new vessels into a cancer, which will then feed the cancer and allow the cancer to grow more readily.
So you don't want to be taking nitric oxide supplements. You don't want to be taking a lot of kale. You can have some kale in your salad, but don't be making kale smoothies or anything like that.
Collier greets is fine. You're fine. Take me there.
Clear dip, a very sensitive Ashwagandha in Jinsing. Can I take the clear dim pro or the clear dim advantage. Yes, or maybe just take the easier aroma clear.
That would probably be your best product. It's just a clear pro doesn't have the other things.
ADK or ADK veil look both look identical because they are the same product. So we have we have a private labeled ADK veil, which is decides for health products as ADK completely could use the same name.
All the same product has 5,000 I use a vitamin D.
But you're your vitamin D is person say my vitamin D is already at 150. Well, I really need you to get the vitamin A out of there. So I'll email you a different product for vitamin A.
It was because of a gene that you have a gene defect, you really need some more vitamin A.
So just hold off on that and I will get you I will email you a different product take to get that vitamin A.
Last to it all the supplements previous and always feel ramped up amtap. What would that be for the TV go? No, would it be for the corseted? Yes, it's probably from the corseting.
It would not be from the bed a gene. Bed a gene would actually probably help call you.
Of course, it is going to help decrease inflammation your brain quite readily to me, but it will be a slower process and it could you can feel amtap after that. So that's not coming.